myself and Andy and our whole show has a
connection to this movie this is based
on a sort of very loosely based or
inspired by a trip you took with a good
friend of ours Dan Ferguson who I've
known for 25 years and you took this
trip with him and it inspired you to
make a movie about two guys taking this
trip to Thailand yeah yeah I actually
met Dan through the show because he's a
segment yeah the show and we met in 98
and early on just became friends and
then found that we were both you know
single and had vacation time around the
same time so we just started traveling
together and we went to Europe we went
to Dubai we were in Micronesia but we
went to Thailand and while we were there
we had a particularly inspiring trip
both the scenery and the circumstances
the the cast of characters that we met
while it was happening I told Dan we're
living in a movie yeah I've got to
figure out how to make this a movie and
I felt like it's a small movie like a
garden state or a sideways like a night
like an organic slice of life kind of
thing but I had to create more dramatic
circumstances because watching an actor
on break and a producer on vacation just
like hanging out in Thailand wasn't
gonna be all that compelling so that's
how Apocalypse Now started it's exactly
yeah and then it just grew and became
about other stuff I've heard Coppola
speak about that yeah it was really a
movie about wine these machines we got
to figure out how to get a helicopter
you guys went when two guys traveled
together there can be misunderstandings
as well everywhere we went they're
typically honeymoon locations so there's
all these couples and people proposing
to each other and people on their
anniversaries and Dan and I were just
two dudes but everybody was so invested
in us having a romantic trip that people
were going out of their way you know
setting us candlelit dinners and
throwing rose petals on our beds and
serving us drinks with two straws and
everyone just had these looks on their
faces like I just want you to have them
I just want you to have a beautiful trip
I think we have a picture inside ap why
there would be a misunderstanding cuz
here's a picture of you two together mix
confusing but you get you get to a point
where everyone is like so invested in
the hospitality that we were just like
let him have it yeah yeah we started
holding hands and yeah yeah why not yeah
you get some free cake out of it what
are you get we might have made out
drunkenly and yeah we know it's Thailand
so
[Laughter]